trust me if I go back to the past I
better put on my Nikes cuz I've better
come gonna be running long [ __ ] five
time travel not possible but imagine if
it were you could hang out with a bunch
of hot robots on a space cruise through
the rings of Saturn or travel to the
past and freak out a bunch of cavemen by
showing them a weird modern invention
like a I don't know a Rubik's Cube time
travel past versus future it's debatable
I think I'm going to go to the past I
would be going to the future I'm going
to the past and I want to go to the
future I'm for the past and I am for the
future I'm a blast from the past I'm for
the future what past thing what do you
really want to to see you can relive old
conversation you can you can wake you
could be like rule of the world dude you
just go back like a thousand years with
like a tec-9 or something down Abbey's
the top of my list why do you want to go
just love don't happy how would fall
asleep in their house just like I fall
asleep in my house when I watch it you
can go to the Middle Ages well lucky
unit I feel like I could end racism if I
could go to the past and come back to
future I'm gonna go back and I am gonna
have sex with every [ __ ] race
possible and but come back here
everyone's me great so would you go back
to like thousand humans like everybody
kind of look yeah I want to go back to a
thousand humans I want to know what they
were doing they were just [ __ ] and
eaten they're gonna freak out when you
arrive they're not that different feel
like they're gonna be like where are you
from I would love to be one of those
guys that poops and it goes down a
chimney because that's what they did in
castle ages I wouldn't go back to first
century AD Israel and meet Jesus because
I can't talk to him probably gonna stone
me for something
Jesus no not Jesus himself but everybody
was stoned everybody for everything back
then I feel like and maybe the Big Bang
would be cool the big if I could just
stand on the outside oxygen doesn't
exist you can in the experience the 60s
Ned would you agree I'm black right yes
I would agree the sixties nah I'm good
you can fix anything by going to the
past oh no you heard of butterflies
crazy you heard a butterfly effect yeah
that's where I was going Oh Pass is set
in stone you changed that us and the
stone get to start shifting up yeah but
if you mess it up dude you just go back
and do it again
yeah responsible now if you go back in
time and punch Hitler you're gonna
change a lot of things and I think
actually going back in time to punch
Hitler sounds good it's a lot of
people's first thought who wouldn't want
to stop Hitler before he killed a bunch
of people Ned's gonna stop Hitler oh
I'll go back in time and kill him when
he's a baby how are you gonna
Hitler he doesn't have the mustache yet
right he's pretty much just a baby wait
oh my god dude
too bad died when he was on top if Tupac
what if it stayed alive I hate to tell
you but he's featured on the next black
eyed peas out he is first off I don't
live in the past all right I'm all about
seeing what's next we have no idea
what's going on in the future if you
want new knowledge go to the future you
don't have to go into pageants go read a
[ __ ] book
you mean like okay this guy killed this
guy this town didn't have good water
the futures the [ __ ] microwave your food
and [ __ ] people are living longer [ __ ]
planes you go to the past you change one
thing and it's changed forever
I go to the future and it's just me like
going to Disneyland just checking things
out what Ryan Seacrest is our president
this is crazy you get a perspective like
what if you go to the future it's a
dystopian hellscape and then you come
back you're just like oh like I guess it
doesn't really matter that it's a Monday
I also like the idea of going to the
future do you bring stuff back I'm gonna
go to the future and try to figure out
how to cure cancer I can just bring back
like a robotic 30-inch big that's how we
defeat cancer that's kind of easy how do
we know that think of that I'm bringing
it to 2016 a 30-inch tick is too big no
one will want that not until there's
like a 30 inch receiving vagina and they
say Zack you're here on I say II know
this isn't me do this and I disappear
into the shadows it would operate like a
collapsible like vagina vaginas go the
other direction you can't just build a
robot vagina
goodness gracious get me to the future
right now I'll buy a one-way ticket not
come back what about your friends and
family people living alone will be way
better off then so they'll probably be
chilling in the Caribbean and Trinidad
listening to steel drums I could also go
to the past and chill in the Caribbean
what if you ran into yourself dude you
could go cause problem you still be
responsible if I ran to myself a baby I
go I knew you was coming you've changed
the future you've changed yourself grow
up all that bad I would change for the
better in the past do man great people
okay here's the great people yeah I'll
imagine what future sex looks like is
that what the keith was talking about
that giant dick what's the future going
to be like some sterile environment
where
they pump your semen into a tube and
then make as big a baby a dystopian
future Bobby looks way better than any
day in the past point-blank period bonk
no comma you can't just say punctuation
and expect it to improve your argument
we know what the past had for us a lot
of bad stuff that we've improved upon we
don't know what the future holds for us
maybe it's good maybe it's bad but the
past I love going to museums I'm done
living in the past I'm all about the
future come with me maybe you'd be
better just to stay here the present is
good the president is a good night good
yeah there's this good we got Wikipedia
Wikipedia and we can watch Downton Abbey
yeah and that's probably better than
going because it'd just be a bunch of
people sweeping
the past smelled terrible there's my
dead relatives body rotting there in the
street also every horse is taking a [ __ ]
on him also I too have taken a [ __ ] next
to where those horses were [ __ ]